miriam me estaba probando su hipótesis
nula de que la media de la población de
un conjunto de datos es igual a 18
contra su hipótesis alternativa en donde
la media es menor a 18 con una muestra
de siete observaciones su prueba
estadística fue t igual a menos 1.9
suponiendo que se satisfacen las
condiciones para la inferencia cuál es
el valor p aproximado para la prueba de
miriam pausa el vídeo y trata de
resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno algo que me gusta hacer es tratar
de entender qué es lo que está pasando
antes de calcular el valor p aquí
tenemos un conjunto de datos una
población y la hipótesis nula dice que
la media verdadera es 18 mientras que la
alternativa dice que es menor a 18 así
que para probar la hipótesis nula miriam
tomó una muestra que tenía un tamaño
igual a 7 y
y ella calculó la media de la muestra y
la desviación estándar para calcular el
estadístico t no nos dicen cómo lo hizo
pero sabemos que el estadístico t es
igual a la media de su muestra menos la
media supuesta en la hipótesis nula eso
es lo que tenemos aquí entre la
aproximación del error estándar de la
media y la forma de hacer esa
aproximación es con la desviación
estándar de la muestra dividida entre la
raíz cuadrada del tamaño de la muestra y
bueno esto ya lo calcularon por nosotros
todo esto es igual a menos 1.9 entonces
si pensamos en una distribución de t
trataré de dibujar la distribución
rápidamente esta es la media de la
distribución de ahora como la hipótesis
alternativa dice que la media es menor a
18 nos interesa saber cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener un valor de que
esté a más de 1.9 por debajo de la media
1.9 por lo tanto nos interesa esta área
para encontrar esta área vamos a usar la
calculadora gráfica de 84 o bueno al
menos un simulador de esta calculadora
todo lo que tenemos que hacer es ir a la
segunda distribución second distribution
en inglés que corresponde a la tecla
second 2nd y después vamos a usar la
función de distribución acumulada para
el estadístico t que en este caso
corresponde al número 6 de ctf pulsamos
enter bien ahora necesitamos que nuestro
límite inferior que es lower down en la
calculadora sea menos infinito porque
esta es una aproximación hacia menos
infinito que es un número muy muy
pequeño y nuestro límite superior que es
oppermann sería menos 1.9
finalmente los grados de libertad son el
tamaño de la muestra menos 1 y como en
este caso el tamaño de la muestra de 7
entonces los grados de libertad que en
la calculadora aparece como de efe por
su origen en inglés que es degrees of
freedom en este caso los grados de
libertad son 6 ahí está por lo tanto
obtenemos que el valor p es de
aproximadamente 0 punto 0 53 el valor p
es aproximadamente igual a cero punto 0
53 así que miriam compararía este valor
p con su nivel de significancia
establecido alfa y si esto es menor que
alfa entonces ella puede rechazar la
hipótesis nula lo que sugeriría la
hipótesis alternativa pero si es mayor
que alfa entonces ella no podrá rechazar
la hipótesis nula
nos vemos en otro vídeo